hey quick announcement the channel now
has official merch head on to
crowdmade.com using the link in the
description or through the pin to
comment okay on with the
[Music]
video when it comes to strange books the
voynich manuscript is in a league of its
own this 15th century text is full of
weird drawings from alien plants with no
biological counterpart to miniature
people operating an array of unknown
machines
and then there's the writing it's
composed in a mystery language complete
with a unique alphabet and grammar to
this day no one has definitively cracked
this ancient code although there are
some out there who claim otherwise the
voynich manuscript is perhaps the most
discussed book of all time
and there are countless theories about
his meaning origin and purpose
let's investigate the world's most
mysterious book and explore the secrets
of the voynich manuscript
[Music]
the official name of this book is
beineckey ms-408
although it's better known as the
voynich manuscript it's named after mr
wilfred voynich an antique collector who
purchased the book in 1912. after his
death it was donated to the beinecke
rare book and manuscript library at yale
university where it resides to this day
it's rarely shown to the public although
a digital version is available to view
online
if you're lucky enough to see the
voynich manuscript in person you'll
notice that it's actually rather small
and a little bit worse for wear but
don't judge a book by its cover inside
it's full of weird illustrations from
alien plants to cryptic star charts and
bathing women in a variety of strange
poses
the manuscript is full of writing with
text made to fit around the drawings
the problem is
no one can actually read it old
manuscripts are hard to read at the best
of times but the voynich brand script is
written in a mystery language complete
with an unknown alphabet the writing is
undoubtedly the most talked about aspect
of this book and has kept code breakers
puzzled for centuries
it's believed that the voynich
manuscript is medieval in origin and the
text images and style look
characteristically european
if we are to unravel the secrets of this
book we want to know more about where it
came from
who wrote it who did it belong to
and most importantly
could it be a hoax
our story starts with wilfred voynich
after whom the manuscript is named after
voynich was a rare book dealer who made
a living buying and selling manuscripts
from his office in london
how he fell into the possession of the
famous manuscript is shrouded in mystery
he apparently purchased it in 1912 from
the college of jesuits in rome the
college had fallen on hard financial
times and had agreed to sell their
collection of books to the vatican the
voynich manuscript was one of those
items due to be sold
but for some unknown reason
30 of these manuscripts ended up in the
hands of wilfrid voynich we don't know
how this transaction took place
although some say
he stole them
ill-gotten or not wilfred voynich's new
manuscript was unlike any in his
collection he was enamored by its
contents and the promise of secrets
therein the voynich manuscript as it
came to be known attracted some of the
greatest minds of the time
this includes william friedman a master
code breaker who famously solved purple
a cipher used by the japanese in world
war ii
friedman spent much of his free time
trying to solve this manuscript but
after four decades of attempts he was
unable to decode it
after voynich's death the book was
eventually sold to a fellow dealer who
then donated it to yale university in
1969
there are those who believe that the
voynich manuscript is a hoax an
elaborate fake created by voynich
himself after all he was never clear
about its origin knowing what he did
about old books could he have fabricated
it himself
claims of forgery used to dominate the
discussion of the voynich manuscript
this was until 2009 when samples of the
book were taken to be carbon dated the
results came back manuscript comes from
the early 15th century specifically
between 1404 to 1438. what's more the
type of ink and the binding techniques
used are also consistent with this era
despite this some raise the possibility
that a carbon dating test can be cheated
say you have a blank medieval parchment
lying about it's possible to add the
writing at a later date this happens a
lot with the dead sea scrolls every year
one or two manuscript fragments are
proven to be fakes
however the voynich manuscript is not a
tiny scrap of paper it's a complete book
it's highly unlikely that there was just
this empty medieval tome lying about
waiting to be written on
no nowadays the voynich manuscript is
widely believed to be genuine
there's another reason why this book is
not a hoax people have known about it
for centuries you see when wilfred
voynich bought the book it came with a
letter
[Music]
dated on the 19th of august 1665 the
letter belonged to one johannes markey a
scientist who lived in prague it was
addressed to athanasius kirkum a
colleague of his the letter discusses
our strange book saying that quote as
soon as it came into my possession i was
convinced that it could be read by no
one except yourself
he then mentions how it was once owned
by emperor rudolf ii who had bought the
book for a great deal of money
according to the letter the author was
roger bacon an english philosopher and
scientist from the 13th century bacon is
especially known for his opus mages a
treatise on everything from grammar to
alchemy could the voynich manuscript be
his long-last almanac then again roger
bacon lived long before the voynich
manuscript was written
we currently don't know the original
author it seems to have been produced
anonymously
whilst in prague the book passed through
a number of hands one owner was george
barresch who wrote about its quote
writing in unknown characters with
pictures of herbs and our varied images
stars and other things
another owner wrote his signature on the
inside cover it's so faint that you can
only view it using multi-spectral
imaging jacobi r tepenech he was a
courtier living in prague and was the
head of emperor rudolph's botanical
gardens perhaps he was interested in the
book's many plant sketches
after its time in prague the manuscript
goes silent for 250 years it resurfaces
in the jesuit college where it was
acquired by wilfrid voynich in 1912.
perhaps it had got there by athanasius
kirkum the recipient of that original
letter kirku was a jesuit and had
perhaps taken the book from prague to
rome
the voynich manuscript has had a
colorful gallery of owners i sadly don't
have the space to tell the full
comprehensive history so the broad idea
will have to do radiocarbon dating has
the early 15th century for the books
creation we don't know who wrote it it's
completely anonymous it's not roger
bacon as he had died a century before
this point
after an undocumented period it surfaces
in prague passing through the hands of
numerous people including emperor rudolf
ii the book then goes unaccounted for
for 250 years but was probably stored in
a jesuit library in rome then under
dubious circumstances
it ends up in the hands of wilfred
voynich
the voynich manuscript's intriguing
history is one facet of this
extraordinary document it's about time
we looked inside and explored the book
through its illustrations
[Music]
in the absence of any readable text the
best place to start is with the images
as strange as they are they're able to
reveal a lot about the meaning and
purpose of the voynich manuscript
the book can be divided each with a
unique topic let's begin with the first
and largest section
comprising roughly half of the voynich
manuscript are plant sketches
each page is dedicated to a single
picture and what we can assume is some
sort of description the plants are
utterly bizarre from the twisted and
tangled to the bright and garish
others look downright alien like this
one it is multiple bulbs pointed leaves
and cubed roots
they don't seem to correspond to
real-life plants
although this one looks like a lily pad
could this be a sunflower
and this might be a viola tricolor
it's a start but the rest of these
botanical impossibilities have left us
guessing as unique as they are the
voynich manuscript is not the only
medieval plant book in fact there's a
whole genre of them called herbals these
are early natural encyclopedia
cataloging all the world's plant life
medieval herbals follow a typical format
what a plant looks like where it grows
and what happens when you eat it in the
medieval world plants were the closest
thing to medicine each plant was
believed to have a specific healing
property some could cure headaches
others toothache or even leprosy
not all plants are beneficial this snake
drawing is a warning that the plant is
poisonous
herbals were popular in both medieval
europe and the middle east whilst they
record an impressive level of early
scientific understanding not all of them
were strictly accurate my favorite
herbals are the ones with mandrakes
plants that have human-like bodies for
roots if pulled out the ground
incorrectly they will shriek loudly
killing anyone within earshot
returning to the voynich manuscript and
we can see just how similar it is to the
medieval herbal even though we can't
read the text it's probably discussing
the properties of each plant
but why are the plants so bizarre
looking at other herbals plants are
drawn rather faithfully yet these are
nearly impossible to identify what's
more the voltage manuscripts drawings
seem well a little crude
the colour is hastily applied and the
line work is a bit rough i know that
medieval manuscript art has its quirks
but they were typically done by
professional illustrators the voynich
manuscript on the other hand looks kind
of amateurish
more the work of a scientist rather than
an artist
it could be that our illustrator based
their plant drawings on descriptions
heard from other people this was quite
common in the medieval era just look at
pictures of elephants i doubt that this
person had ever seen one in real life
it remains uncertain all we can say is
that this section of the hornet's
manuscript is some sort of herbal an
encyclopedia of various plants and their
properties other than that it's anyone's
guess
next up are two sections dedicated to
the stars i'll talk about them together
as they're rather similar these sections
are full of circular charts some of
which fold out into large spreads the
designs are beautiful to look at even if
we have no clue what they mean
in the section dealing with astrology we
have some recognizable zodiac symbols
for example pisces taurus and libra
orbiting them are women holding stars
they're heavily annotated perhaps
representing some sort of constellation
why the sudden shift from plants to
space
well it might have to do with medicine
in medieval times medicine and astrology
were deeply linked when you took
something was just as important as what
you took
this astrology manual gives health
advice based on the season in the months
of leo it's recommended to take medicine
for the stomach the heart and the liver
but bloodletting is to be avoided aries
is a better time to bloodlet but be sure
not to take medicine for the head seeing
as astrology and healthcare were once
linked perhaps those star charts aren't
so random after all maybe these sections
were some sort of reference sheet
outlining the best times to take a
particular medicine on a quick side note
this is the only section that has
readable text beneath each zodiac sign
is the corresponding month written in a
language that resembles french we have
aberil
mai aust
and novombra the closest match is okitan
a language that was once widely spoken
in the south of france this strange
detail may point to the manuscript's
location of origin
sandwiched between the astrology and
cosmology sections is one of the weirder
parts of the voynich manuscript if it
hadn't been weird enough already the
section is full of miniature naked women
washing in giant bathtubs the section
looks like the most fun with water
slides and aquatic conga lines as you
turn the pages the illustrations get
increasingly strange with curling pipes
of water and tubes transporting green
liquids
the people seem to be operating them
although their purpose is unclear
as you may have expected by now there
are other medieval books dedicated to
bathing and washing
many of these drawings look quite
similar to the ones found in the voynich
manuscript
this is an early guidebook to all the
public baths and hot springs across
italy each bath was believed to have a
special effect or soothe a particular
part of the body
this health focus seems to match what
we've already seen in the voynich
manuscript
if the plant and astrology sections have
been about healthcare
why not throw hygiene into the mix by
the looks of things the voynich
manuscript records some pretty unusual
bathing methods maybe these sketches are
some form of early shower
the book briefly returns to plant
drawings this time however the layout is
rather different it showcases roots and
herbs of all different shapes and sizes
beside them are drawings of mysteriously
coloured cylinders it's difficult to
make out what they are perhaps some sort
of container
it looks a bit like laboratory equipment
particularly the type used for alchemy
other alchemy textbooks from this period
look rather similar with drawings of
beakers and test tubes in the margins
it's possible but alchemists dealt with
precious metals and rocks not roots and
herbs
the equipment might have belonged to an
apothecary someone who creates herbal
medicine if so the section has some sort
of medical or scientific focus
similar to what we've already seen
surround the voynich manuscript the
final section is the one we know least
about largely because it's entirely in
text since we don't know what it says
there's not much to go on running down
the margin they're what look like stars
they could be bullet points seeing as
the adjacent letters have been
capitalized
some dubbed this section the recipes
suggesting that it's a guide to making
potions
i'm not sure that this is a helpful
title as the writing could be about
something completely different it's a
mystery if only we knew what the writing
said once this section concludes the
book comes to an end
judging by the images alone the voynich
manuscript looks like some sort of
health almanac its various sections can
be linked to medieval textbooks
from herbals to zodiac charts and guides
on the magic of bathtime whilst it has
much with the literature of the time the
voynich manuscript is far stranger than
anything from that era from plants that
are nearly impossible to identify to
bathing machines that defy logic
having looked at the illustrations
there's one thing left to explore the
writing
the images can take us so far but what
does the text say let's take a closer
look at this writing and attempt to
figure out the mystery language
looking past the illustrations and
focusing now on the writing the first
thing you will notice is the unique
alphabet
some letters are from the latin script
like these lowercase letters yet there
are some that look like numerals then
you have these tall looping characters
they've been nicknamed gallows letters
as they share an eerie resemblance to a
hangman's scaffold
overall there are 22 letters in this
alphabet although every now and then you
might spot a unique symbol in the mix
like other european languages the
voynich manuscript combines letters to
make words they're relatively short
ranging from two to ten letters and are
separated by spaces finally the writing
reads from left to right across the page
many believe that what we're dealing
with is a cipher a cipher is a way of
disguising language often by swapping
letters out for symbols
most ciphers hide information and
protect classified material from getting
out this was certainly the case with the
copial cipher the writing is a mix of
latin and greek letters but with some
unique symbols for good measure if
you've watched my video on this you'll
know that was eventually solved the book
contains instructions on initiation
rituals and is believed to have belonged
to a secret society called the oculists
whilst it may look like a scrambled mass
of letters the code wasn't too difficult
to finally break the best way to decode
a cipher is to figure out the original
language behind it
like people every language has a unique
fingerprint some languages like big
words others have lots of consonants and
not a lot of vowels
these fingerprints remain even when the
letters are assigned symbols
with the kopiel cipher it looked like it
was written in german
using a machine algorithm they figured
out some of the letters after that the
rest fell in place
the key to breaking a cipher is to
figure out the original language if you
know that
you can crack the code the problem with
the voynich manuscript is that figuring
out the original language has proven
challenging
mainly because it doesn't have any of
those fingerprints it doesn't seem to
behave like any known language there
seems to be order in the text there are
repeating patterns across the page just
like any other language if it was
written in random gibberish you would
not expect to see this kind of
uniformity to make things more difficult
researchers have found the presence of
not one but two languages in the voynich
manuscript most of the book is written
in what's been called language a whereas
the bath and star sections seem to be
written in language b
judging by the handwriting they may
correspond to different authors one
person seems to have written solely in
language a and up to four in language b
if this is a cipher text we are dealing
with an incredibly sophisticated one
especially as there are two languages to
deal with
there are ways to help us figure out the
language the first test you can do is to
look at word distribution which words
are common and which ones are rare if
the voynich manuscript has a pattern of
common and rare words that's a hint that
there really is a language underneath
the most commonly used english word is
the if you rank the most common words
you'll find that the word the accounts
for seven percent of all words that are
spoken the runner-up of is about 3.5
half of that
strangely all languages seem to follow
this pattern where the second most
common word is used half as much as the
first and so on in the voynich
manuscript both languages follow this
rule the second most common word appears
half as much as the first this shows
that the voynich manuscript is operating
like a real language proof that it's not
just random gibberish across the page
okay so it's definitely a language but
which language is it what will help us
out here is to look at the spelling
specifically how predictable are some
letters over others in english wherever
there's a queue there's almost always a
u
queen
question quadruped to name a few this is
one of english's fingerprints that a q
is typically followed by you now the
voynich manuscript has a lot of these
letter patterns
way more than english
in fact voyniches is super predictable
when you see this letter it's almost
always followed by this one
only a few letters appear at the start
of words and some are unique to the ends
whatever this language is it's very
mechanical something you would not
expect to see in natural languages this
has put a spanner in the works yes the
voynich manuscript contains a language
but not like any language we know of
a third and final method people have
used is looking for keywords unique
words that only appear in certain
sections of the manuscript this is where
pictures can really help out it gives us
a hint as to the subject matter looking
for keywords researchers have found that
the plant and root sections have a lot
of words in common as both seem to be
about herbs perhaps these words have
something to do with that unfortunately
it doesn't tell us what the words
actually are
only what they might mean
in the end it's still just guesswork
it's not much but it's a start what
looking for keywords does show is that
the manuscript is clearly talking about
something it's a tantalising detail but
another hint that there is a real
language lurking underneath
what i've summarized are the main three
approaches at deciphering the voynich
manuscript
looking at how words are distributed
reveals a pattern of common and rare
words something that shows is not just
random gibberish but a functioning
language looking at how words are
spelled reveals that the letters follow
a very predictable pattern far more so
than any other known language
finally looking for keywords reveals
that there are clusters of unique words
in the plants and root sections
indicating that those words are relevant
to those topics
you can see why it's been so difficult
for cryptographers to solve the mystery
language of the voynich manuscript
it looks like a language but not like
any language we know of
despite this there are some who've
claimed to have cracked the code of the
voynich manuscript
others still have claimed to have
translated it
let's review the various attempts and
see what we can find
a common suggestion is that the mystery
writing is some sort of romance language
these are languages that are descended
from latin like italian french and
spanish people have put forward theories
from
an abbreviated form of latin italian
that's been jumbled into anagrams or
perhaps an ancestral form of latin a
proto-romance language
seeing as these languages were and still
are the dominant languages of western
europe it's not a bad guess by any means
what's more the only writing we can read
in the voynich manuscript is in one of
these languages
if you remember those month names are
written in okatan which is a cousin of
french whilst it might fit into the
historical and geographical context
actually proving this hunch has not been
very successful
perhaps it's some other language like
ukrainian turkish or english
some have gone outside the box and
suggested it's written in an aztec
language arguing that the plants could
be native to mexico i unfortunately
can't talk about every theory
individually i will say that none of
them have gained much traction either
one theory that did cause a stir was in
2016 when two researchers tried to show
it was an encrypted form of hebrew using
an algorithm they developed they
demonstrated that this sentence could be
deciphered into this as neither them are
hebrew speakers they had to use google
translate to complete the rest resulting
in this sentence
although this paper created a lot of
buzz at the time their methods are a
little shaky especially as they relied
on google translate what's more the
hebrew sentence they come up with
doesn't make much grammatical sense to
begin with nor does the translation for
that matter
it's always tempting to believe these
bold theories that have claimed to have
solved the voynich manuscript as of
today no one has definitively found the
language to match the text but what if
the voynich manuscript was written in a
language that we don't know about
perhaps this book contains the last
surviving evidence of a long forgotten
tongue this might sound outlandish but
there are some real life examples of
this
one such case is the rongo rongo tablet
it was discovered on easter island in
the pacific famous for its moai statues
it's covered in markings arranged in
such a way that resemble pictographic
writing since the island was deserted
it's believed that the speakers of rongo
rongo long since left the island or
perished leaving an eerie shadow of the
language they once spoke perhaps the
voynich manuscript is a long-lost
european language an intriguing theory
but one with significant problems for
example the varnish manuscript does not
resemble any language found in europe
language isolates do exist in europe
like basque but there's no evidence of a
tribe of people who once spoke voynich
ease how could a language as unique as
this one have gone undetected
unless we find a rosetta stone with
voynich writing on it this line of
inquiry too remains inconclusive
verging on the doubtful
at this point many just give up the
search and settle that the voynich
manuscript is a hoax the whole thing is
a nonsense language made to accompany
nonsense images
maybe the whole thing is a prank with a
convincingly fake language made using
some sort of encrypting technique
after all the letters do appear in such
a predictable manner another reason why
the language could be fake is that there
are zero mistakes no crossings out no
corrections it's a little bit eerie
almost every medieval manuscript has
some sort of error
if these are all just meaningless words
then technically there's no such thing
as a mistake hence zero corrections
maybe the writing is a decoy maybe we've
fallen for one big medieval prank
sed is a medieval hoax why go to the
effort to create the manuscript in the
first place complete with a functioning
language since manuscripts as this one
would have been very expensive to
produce why waste all that money on a
practical joke i don't buy it to me view
suggesting that the voynich manuscript
is an ancient hoax don't do justice to
its complexity and those who
underestimate the book have probably
been outsmarted by it the voynich
manuscript is frustrating but there is
meaning in those pages we just have more
work to do
this brings us to the final theory about
the voynich manuscript it may have been
written in a constructed language an
artificial way of speaking made from
scratch esperanto is an example of a
constructed language it's an
amalgamation of numerous european
languages and was developed in 1887 by
dr l l zamerhoff esperanto is the most
widely used constructed language with
about 100 000 speakers
another fan of constructed languages was
j.r.r tolkien the author of lord of the
rings an avid linguist tolkien created a
slew of languages that were spoken
across middle earth like quenya a type
of elvish it has its own vocabulary and
grammar along with an alphabet which
looks like medieval writing maybe the
voynich manuscript is written in a
constructed language an invented tongue
whose rules we do not yet know
this might explain several things from
the unique alphabet to the fact that it
behaves like a language yet none that
we've ever seen before
the practice of constructing languages
stretches way back into history one of
which was the lingua ignota or unknown
language of hildegard von bingen dating
to the 12th century this language is a
strange set of words reported to be
divine in origin we don't have the
grammar just the vocabulary
but it did have its own alphabet which
looked like this
many constructed languages were early
attempts at creating the world's first
universal language many were pioneered
by philosophers and scientists who
wanted their research to transcend
linguistic barriers
it could be that the writing in the
voynich manuscript was an early attempt
at creating one of these
seeing as the book is scientific in
nature maybe it was using an
experimental tongue in hopes of reaching
a wider audience if this is the case it
would have the opposite effect to a
cipher a cipher is used to hide
information using code to conceal but if
this code is an attempt at some sort of
universal language then it's trying to
be more accessible however the rules of
this ambitious language seem to have
been forgotten
meaning that rather ironically now no
one can read it
no theory is 100 plausible and there are
of course some difficulties that need to
be explained
no matter how original constructed
languages tend to be based on one or
more natural languages esperanto is a
composite of all european languages
and tolkien's quenia is based on finnish
if the voynich manuscript contained a
constructed language we'd expect it to
be using a natural language as a
template
or two seeing as there are two languages
contained in the book and why not use
latin that was the universal language of
academia in the middle ages
so far the mystery language of the
voynich manuscript remains undeciphered
perhaps it always will
arriving at the end of this
investigation let's recap everything we
know the voynich manuscript is a real
medieval book and has been carbon dated
to the early 1400s we're not dealing
with a modern hoax in fact it's passed
through the hands of many over the years
from scientists emperors and collectors
although we still don't actually know
who wrote it the illustrations hint at
the book's original purpose its images
have much in common with medieval
herbals astrology guides and bathing
manuals making it likely that the
voynich manuscript was some sort of
medical textbook although a very strange
one by any measure
then there's the writing the most
enigmatic aspect of the book it's
written in a mystery language with a
unique alphabet and grammatical rules
as we've seen theories range from
real-life languages written in code to
ones that are invented from scratch as
of this video's upload no one has been
able to definitively solve the voynich
manuscripts language
from my research the closest parallel to
the voynich manuscript is this it's a
text from the welcome collection
featuring apocalyptic scenes from the
book of revelation aside from the
biblical scenes you can also find
details on science and human anatomy
with these strange images of various
injuries what's more for a time the
language of this document was unknown
researchers have been able to determine
that it's a mixture of german and latin
and have since been able to translate it
perhaps the answer to the voynich
manuscript is in text like these
with the book as complex as the voynich
manuscript there's plenty i've not been
able to talk about like how some of the
pages might be missing and whether
multiple authors wrote the book i hope
that this video has inspired you to
investigate the book for yourself
links and resources are down in the
description below so you can get started
the voynich manuscript is well deserving
of the title the most mysterious book of
all time every aspect of this document
is fascinating from its history
illustrations to its writing to my mind
the fact that almost nothing is known
about this manuscript is the reason why
it's so appealing sometimes i wonder
whether we actually solved it would the
magic of mystery disappear or would we
uncover a whole new set of questions and
embark on another journey entirely
in the strange and wonderful pages of
the voynich manuscript lie so many
untold secrets
secrets that may one day
be finally revealed
[Music]
hey thanks for watching i really hope
you enjoyed this one it's a massive
topic that deserved a real deep dive
yes so the channel now has official
merch we have beanies t-shirts and
hoodies the designs are inspired by
biker gang patches and playoff hells
angels head on to crowdmade.com using
the link in the description or through
the pinned comment if you like this
video and want to see more why not
subscribe a like and a comment also go a
really long way anyway i look forward to
seeing you next time
goodbye